الاختلاف في الراي
لا يفسدوا للوطن قضيه
بلؤكد لكم ان حجم التنوع والاختلاف في
الرؤى والاطروحات
يعزز بقوه من كفاءه المخرجات
التي انتظرها من جمعكم الكريم بهذه الكلمه
المسجله افتتح الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي جلسات الحوار الوطني مرسلا رساله
تطمين ان مخرجاته ستكون موضعه تنفيذ من
قبل الدوله باجهزتها او من خلال سلطاتها
التشريعيه اولا اذا احتاج الامر لمثل هذا
الاجراء وهو ما لمسه المشاركون الذين
انتظروا على مدار عام كامل قيام مجلس
امناء الحوار الوطني بالاعداد لمحاوره
الثلاثه السياسيه والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
هتنتهي بتوصيات ولكن قائد التنفيذ بدانا
نسمع عن حاجات هتحال الى المجلس يعني
الفكره اللي كانت طرحت بتاعه مد الاشراف
القضاء على الانتخابات اللي هو المفروض
ينتهي في يناير اللي جاي ده يعني كانت
توصيه مبدئيه سياده الرئيس وافق عليها
واعتقد ان الحوار الوطني هيحلها المجلس
النواب للموافقه وتعديل القانون فلا يعني
الموضوع هيبقى فيه خطوات سريعه يعني
اجراءات اخرى مشجعه اخذتها الدوله من خلال
الافراج عن عدد كبير من سجناء الراي الامر
الذي رفع من سقف الطموحات عند المشاركين
هناك ازمات مزمنه منذ عقود طويله جدا
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وسياسيه وتتفاقم ولكن
اعتقد الان نحن نفتح كل هذه
الملفات تقريبا نحن نتحدث عن 113 قضيه
مطروحه للنقاش وهذه لاول مره في تاريخ مصر
عموما التاريخ مصر الحديث كله ان يتم طرح
كل هذه القضايا بدون سقف وبدون محظورات
بدون خطوط حمراء رئيس مجلس الوزراء وعدد
من الوزراء حضروا انطلاق الجلسات مع
التاكيد علنيه السلطه التنفيذيه المشاركه
في الحوار الوطني ولكن الملفت للنظر ان
اقل نسبه مشاركه في المقترحات جاءت من
الاحزاب اذ قام 60% منها فقط لتقديم
المقترحات عدم مشاركه حزب هو اصلا مغلق او
هو اصلا غير مفعل فده مشكله الحازمي مش
مشكله يعني ده اعتقد ان هو مقترح اهتمام
بيبقى فيه عندنا تفعيل ليه دور الاحزاب
السياسيه والاحزاب الغير مفعله وغير لها
دور او لها سجل نشاط تتم اسقاط عضويتها ما
لم يثبت نشاطها يعني غالبيه المقترحات
التي تلقتها الامانه العامه جاءت فيما يخص
المحور الاقتصادي فهو الاكثر ايلاما على
مستوى مجتمع الاعمال والنقابات والغرف
والمواطنين بصفه عامه تامر نصرت العربيه
القاهره
ومتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات